all right sonia
yeah sonia where'd you girl where are
you from originally um albuquerque new
mexico albuquerque and tell me about
your family growing up you had
both your parents um
yeah i did um
and my sisters my two sisters
um
how would you describe your childhood
horrible
um
in what ways
my dad
raped me and my sisters growing up
from that i can remember like age three
till i was nine
we went to foster care
did he get caught yeah he was charged he
got 21 years
my mom
it's my biological father not my sisters
and my mom to seem to like blame
everything on me
in a way
um
i got
i was in foster care my sisters got out
of foster care went back to my mom
after a while i was wondering why i
wasn't my mom didn't want me
my sister finally made my mom take me
home
and then at 11
i came home from school with all my
stuff packed up and my mom told me i had
to leave um
from there i met
my kids dad
um
i was 13
had my first baby i got five kids
um
so
and then just it was a bad relationship
with my kids dad he beat me like
severely beat me
um
all the way from 13 until i was
22
and then
i had left him finally
and
started getting my life together
and
then my son my three-year-old son
was killed
my sister beat my son to death
and from there i kind of lost i lost it
for a while i lost
lost it
um
[Music]
i started trying to commit suicide
got really heavy into drugs
just
and i didn't want to be back home
where everything had happened and so i
three o'clock in the morning one night
left
and hitchhiked
and got dropped off in watts
california
at like three four in the morning
at the rosso park station and
i've been in california since
it's been hell out here too as a female
on the streets
i've been raped i've been beat i've been
hit by a car had 147 stitches like
intentionally um the guy ran me over
i was kidnapped stuffed stuffed in the
trunk of a car for two days stabbed
right here
woke up 12 days later in icu
because they had hit an artery
just
it's been it's been tough and
i don't know it's kind of like i want to
get my life together but at the same
time like i feel like i've given up a
lot
just
not really having anybody i don't have
nobody i don't
my mom's side of family they pretty much
disown me because
they blame me for what my father did
my dad's side pretty much disown me
because they don't believe that it
happened
so
i'm literally like out here by myself
where are your other kids
um they are
with family
um
through my children's dad's side of the
family
yeah
and you're living right now
um back and forth between here well yeah
here in lancaster
i kind of just
when i get tired of
all the crap in lancaster i come out
here when i get tired of here i go back
to lancaster yeah there's crap in both
places yeah it really is
and you're just basically homeless
you're just
winging it night by night yeah
and the drugs are part of your life too
yes
what's your drug currently
crystal and ecstasy
where did that start
well i've kind of been
off and on with crystal for
a while like my childhood my parents
used to cook meth
in a little camper trailer we were all
living in
so it's it's been in my life like
pretty much my
my whole life but
i was able to
to smoke
and then
stay clean for like months at a time
and
not have a problem with it now like
since 2018 i don't think i've been
completely sober
one time since 2018.
it's hard to like function without it
now it feels like
do you have anybody in your life now i
mean do you have contact with your
family no
i don't want contact with my family
i just
they've made my life
hard
and they've made my life hell i've tried
to mend things with my mom so many times
but she just
she don't want it
i matter of fact i called her on
mother's day
well i called my sister spoke to my
sister
and
tried to talk to my mom my mom wouldn't
talk to me and
i had it upset me so bad that i hung up
the phone and i texted my sister and i
told her i said hey
do you think mom would even care if i
died like do you think she would care
and my sister was like just know that i
would care
i'm like damn that's that's kind of cold
like i don't understand
being a mother i don't understand how a
mother could just
just
not have any care in the world for her
own child like i don't know
because even my kids not being with me i
still i think about my kids every day
and i love my kids to death
but
yeah how often do you talk to your kids
um made it
their choice um
i felt at 13 it would be an okay age for
them to possibly comprehend everything
that had happened
and
i felt at the age 13
you know
what family does have them
for them to sit them down and talk to
them and
it be their choice whether they want me
in their life or not
and
i can't be angry with them if they don't
i can't
that's something that i have
have to accept so you've been waiting
for them to call you
yeah
i just don't i don't want to confuse
them i don't want
i don't want to make things harder in
school
and all that because like i said i've
been in foster care
and
like
it's hard it's hard having
it's like being pulled both ways
or
you know me not being able to me telling
them i'm coming to see them and then not
being able to make it
and
that's hard on a child that is that is
really hard on a child my mom used to do
it to us all the time oh i'm coming to
see you coming to visit
and want to show up to our visits
and that [ __ ] hurts and that [ __ ] really
messes the message with you
mentally emotionally it has an effect on
school
like just
a lot it has a lot
yeah so i didn't want that for my kids
i wanted
most of all i wanted my kids to have a
way better life than i did growing up i
wanted them to
to not go through any of the stuff i
went through
and just
yeah i just wanted them to have a way
better life than i did and i possibly i
couldn't give that to them at the time
how do you support yourself now
um
just hustling
i recycle um
just whatever do you do do you date guys
for nope you don't no i really don't
you're one of the few it's crazy because
that is something that his
because
i like to dress provocative that's just
that's just me
but that has
i was just recently engaged to a guy and
he swore up and down sword but now i was
working on the i was prostituting
and it like literally ripped
our relationship apart and i'm like
if i could understand if i was losing
him over
stuff that i was doing
because then i mean that's i have to
accept that but
to lose
somebody you really like care about and
love like or something that you're
really not doing
it's hard it's hard and
but
i i guess
the way i dress the way i'm just like
i don't know i get it all the time
though all the time
everybody
thinks i thought i'd be out here doing
that and i'm like no
what emotions do you go through living
this lifestyle
um
to be honest with you like
at this point i'm pretty numb
that's how i feel
um
i'm not gonna lie there's there's times
that
i sit and i think about my kids i think
about just
everything i think about if my mom would
have cared if
i would have had a different child just
i think about a lot of things and
and it's hard i i'm like i said i battle
uh i battle suicide like i
like
a lot
a lot a lot
that's i got scars
on my legs from me like literally just
like losing it and just
cutting my legs like crazy like actually
like cutting them cutting them
um
i have scars all at my arms
i've tried to od
i've
it's hard it's hard to do it it's
not having anybody it's it's hard and
then
i go through hell on the streets because
people look at me like
like okay
if we rob her
or we beat her or we rape her or
whatever she's not going to go to the
police because i don't want to be called
a snitch
because it's going to make it harder for
me
but
she's not going to go to the police
she doesn't have anybody that's going to
back her up
she ain't going to do nothing so
there's no consequences to what we do to
her and that's how really how they look
at me i've had people tell me that
like and that's hard that's hard
really hard
i've had dudes burn my tents my tent
down
in the middle of the night because i
won't sleep with them i
i go i go through a lot it's hard
i don't i say i don't wish
being homeless
even on my worst enemies
i don't
it's hard
and to even live with the fact that
everybody looks at you so crazy
everybody looks at you like you're nasty
like you're
um
and i mean i i can see that you know
some people don't take care of
themselves but
i feel like that's because
they get lost
they
they quit caring
they
i have to remind myself every day every
day
to be numb
is one thing but to like just
not care anymore about nothing
i can't do that to myself
um
yeah
it's
it's hard
what are you afraid of now
not
making
just
either ending up dead
okay i'll be honest with you my biggest
fear my biggest fear in life honestly is
because i don't have nobody
like i'm so scared that i'm gonna end up
like
mangled up in a bush somewhere
dead and ain't nobody even gonna know
because ain't nobody gonna look for me
like that's my biggest fear
because it happens too often to females
out here
they end up dead
it just scares me like to know that i
don't even have anybody that would look
for me
like
i disappear you know i i come and i go
because i don't have anybody so i don't
even it wouldn't even be a thought in
somebody's mind like oh we haven't seen
her you know wonder it just
yeah it sucks
it really sucks
do you have any friends
real friends
i do um
i have two that i would consider
real friends
um
but they got a lot going on in their
lives too
right now
and i try not to put
that stress on them
are there things about this life that
you like
the freedom the lack of responsibility
that
i wanted to say the lack of
responsibility but
just being out outdoors i guess
i'm a very outdoors person
whether it comes to like
you're sleeping outdoors every night
yeah
like
out in lancaster i
i don't normally i got to wear about a
year and a half almost two years ago
i quit sleeping in tents because they
kept getting burnt down
so like i always build
me like a little a little shack thing
you know something
something that's at least somewhat
comfortable somewhat
a little bit more clean
i just i don't i don't want to let
myself go
because i i feel that i have way more
potential than that
i just
it's hard it's hard to find work too
because like
just
my childhood just everything i have
really bad ptsd i have
um
i'm bipolar
and i just i have really bad anxiety
so when i start to get around a lot of
people i start panicking i start feeling
like like i can't breathe i start
freaking out
i feel like like everybody's closing in
on me i start feeling like everybody's
judging me
it's just
it's hard it's
hard
i'm always looking for work but
my type of work is like
something under the table something you
know i mean like something to where i
won't have to really deal with a lot of
people like house cleaning stuff like
that
um just so i don't have to deal with so
many people
but what would you have done differently
in your life if you could have
um
i would have kept going through school
actually no you know what
to be honest with you
and a lot of people say i'm crazy for
this but
i'll be honest with you i really
wouldn't change anything only because
i know that at some point
things are going to get better
and
everything that i've been through has
only made me stronger
it's only made me i'm not happy with
where i am in life but i'm happy with
who i am
um
because i know i'm very strong
therefore
i don't think i don't think i would
change
anything because
at this point it's just it's a journey
um
it's a hard journey but it's a journey
and
i know that at the end of the
the end of the road like when everything
starts to get better for me
i just know that i'm going to be that
much stronger
and
yeah
you feel like the sexual abuse you
went through as a child
kind of changed the
the path of your life
yeah
absolutely it always does it seems
yeah
um
man
yeah it did it did a lot
um
i used to have i haven't in a very long
time but i used to have like
um flashbacks night terrors
um
wake up
freaking out in the middle of the night
screaming
now that i use drugs i don't because i
don't sleep very often honestly
that's actually my main
that's my main reason for using crystals
because i just i don't want to go to
sleep i don't
it's hard to lay down at night
alone
in the cold
they just it's hard it really is hard um
mostly alone like that's that's that's
my biggest problem is just being alone
like i'm i'm
i'm so alone
like people i hear people all the time
like oh i don't have no family i don't
have this but then you know you see i'm
talking to this per you know they got
this uncle they said
like i really don't have anybody like i
every great one small i talk to my
sister
and
like every great once in a while i don't
get happy birthdays i don't get merry
christmas i don't get
nobody contacts me on holidays
and
sometimes i i just think to myself like
what what did i do like what did i do
to them
to deserve this but then i have to
realize like i was a child
when all this started i was a child and
being a mother
there's nothing
my child could do
that could possibly make me
not love them or
or be so hateful so
careless
towards them
people
are always like oh well you don't have
your kids so what is that i don't have
my kids because i was a stronger person
and i realized that i couldn't give my
kids the life that they deserved
and i was able to people call it selfish
but
really it's not because
i suffer every day without my kids i
hurt every day without my kids
just so my kids could be happy so my
kids could have a better life so i don't
feel it's selfish
um
i miss my kids all the time all the time
what's been the lowest point of your
life
right now right now
yeah
the streets are tough
yeah they really are
it's
like i said i wouldn't wish it on even
my worst enemy to be out here
was the best time in your life
having my kids
[Music]
do you feel like you were loved as a
child no no
didn't have to think about that one yeah
i've
i've actually i've told my mom
like
at one point i had told her i said
i called her and i asked her for help
that's my money i like i really need
some help like i really need help she's
like with what
i said myself she's like what are you
talking about like i'm scared she's just
a what i'm myself like i'm scared of
myself i need help can you get me some
help like
i'm terrified
and she said
what the [ __ ] do you expect me to do for
you
and she hung up the phone
and i'm like damn
like i'm literally begging to her for
help because i'm i'm scared of myself
when a person becomes scared of
themselves
that's bad
and as my mother she couldn't even help
me
and or didn't even want to even try to
help me
and
a couple weeks later i had talked to her
and i told her i said
i said i just want to be able to sit
down
and just be able to take
a big deep breath in and just
let it out and
and feel okay for once feel just okay
and i told her i said
i can't even remember back
to when i was a child i don't even
remember
being okay then because i was going
through the rape with my dad
by the time i started remembering things
you know
um
like i've been i've i've
i've felt like the tightness this this
heavy weight right here in my chest
since i was little
like i just i want to know what it feels
like to to just
be okay
you describe yourself as
self-destructive
um
[Music]
i mean obviously because i've got kind
of i
really can't say no
but
when things get overwhelming
and
and i feel like i just i can't handle no
more
i would rather do
harm to myself than to somebody else
honestly um
but then it's not even that it's just
the fact of
when everything gets overwhelming i just
i don't i feel like i don't want to be
here like i feel like they're what's the
point
that's how that's how i feel and
i just yeah i just
there's times that i just i don't want
to be here
there
was a point in
my life just recently where i went
through a stage where
i felt like
i had asked somebody i said
you know
people wake up in the morning and they
thank god
that they woke up another day
i'm like but do you know what it feels
like to wake up in the morning angry
with god that you woke up
like
just
straight anger
because
you lived another day you woke up
another day
and i hate that feeling
as
as humans we should love
our life we should be grateful for our
life
and for
a person to
go through so much to where they just
to where they're angry that that they
have life
it's just it's
it sucks
it sucks
and
it sucks even more because i don't i
don't want people to look at me like oh
i'm so sorry i don't want that from
people like i don't
to me that that's negative attention to
me
um
[Music]
but like
i would honestly i would be happy if
people could look at my life and realize
that
hey
there's girls out here that are going
through the same thing or worse and
find some help for females like me
these streets are
they're nasty
they're
man there's there's women
and of course men too there's there's
people there's innocent people out here
losing their lives left and right
just because they're out
here people
very good-hearted people people that
that don't
be doing bad things
they're ending up
dead out here
like it's like people it's like we we
end up homeless and slowly like our
families
start to just forget about us
um
we just become like nobody
like
and it's sad it's really sad
so your drugs are ecstasy and meth yeah
what does your typical day look like
using those drugs
what do you mean you don't wake up in
the morning because you're probably up
on that
right
schedule that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about
it's a zoo out there it is a matter of
fact this morning
me and my friend had a gun pulled on us
because my friend told some guy good
morning he's like come on
how's your morning he's like what and
the guy like started like throwing gang
signs and he ends up pulling a gun out
i'm like well bro like let's just go i'm
like that's negative attention i'm
trying to teach my my friend he's
younger than me
i'm like
quit feeding into the negative like
the unnecessary [ __ ] is what i do
unnecessary [ __ ] it's just
if it's
cut it simple if somebody starts to get
upset angry we
we may be able to handle it as an adult
we may be able to realize that
that we're not upset we're not angry
about it but can they
at that point just walk away just walk
away
like
because my
people are out here just left and right
killing each other
over nothing
and like being homeless we're right in
like the middle of it all
sonia what did you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
the most important thing
would be
oh
i don't know like i can't i really can't
say
one thing you know like because
i've learned a lot if you're intelligent
there's probably a whole
bunch i've learned yeah i've learned a
lot um
i try i try to be respectful i've
learned
like
just because other people are
disrespectful
doesn't mean that i have to be
disrespectful because two wrongs don't
make a right
and
you never know what
another person's going through
um you don't know if they just woke up
to to their child being dead or their
mother being dead or you don't know that
i try to be understanding
considerate of other people
and just
and to be humble that kind of sums just
all that up you know
to be humble
excellent all right sonia thank you so
much for sharing your story yeah
i wish you the best of luck out there
thank you
you